nightfall in the pakistani capital
islamabad
while others make their way home faisana
is getting ready for work
tonight she's downed a few glasses of
whiskey something she does regularly
before setting off
a man so i can forget who i am
the 34 year old began working as a
prostitute four years ago
she says it's the only way she's been
able to support her two children since
her husband died
of my husband after his death i tried to
earn money by selling furniture and
other items from my house at times i
couldn't even feed my children
so one day i went over to a friend of
mine to borrow some money
she introduced me to this work
video
several clients contact faisana during
the interview
among them are politicians and
businessmen as well as mullers and
foreign diplomats
she often sees eight or nine men a night
her family has no idea how she earns a
living
i can't forgive myself for doing what i
do
it's a sin and i know that i'll be
punished for it in the afterlife
i pray that god will send me an angel to
change my life
in pakistan respectability only comes
with a husband
something faizana dreams of instead she
lives in constant fear of being caught
by the police
here it's illegal to have sex outside of
wedlock
women's rights activist fazana bari
describes what happens to those who
break the law
so this kind of islamic punishment both
for a married you know man and a woman
who are who indulge in
prostitution or adultery then
stoning to death otherwise if you're
unmarried then
a hundred lectures for both young girls
despite that prostitution remains
widespread in pakistan
it is in the knowledge of the local
police you know
and normally is because the corruption
and they they also get
um you know some of these bribes and
then
they let that happen you know so they
just turn blind eye
to towards uh prostitution which takes
place
we are in a society in the state of
denial you know
that these are the things which do not
happen in pakistan
so therefore they rather than discussing
and you know they
they rather deny that it happens because
we are muslim society
so there is no extra marital sex you
know
as a result buying sex is relatively
easy in pakistan
in areas like this men women
transsexuals and even children
line the streets offering their services
activists want the government to face up
to reality
that these people need to be protected
and not stigmatized
you